[Music]
and find over Facebook news submitted by
JK fan come to Somme beyond oh please
I like Santiago who are in the way great
whether you world to know Sea World
you love the world know why do you let
you move because the penguin exhibit is
pretty cool they have a aquarium area
where you can see all the fishes of the
world like a South American and all that
stuff and they have shows these in
Mexican penguins they have this ride
it's kind of like the log ride at
Disneyland but they copied it pretty
cool there are a lot of reasons to like
SeaWorld no but see us going there and
not going to doesn't change the fact
that those beautiful whales are there
now it's great for us to go and support
them
no I seat with my dollar I will never
shut the [ __ ] off my boss zero I [ __ ]
hate the woman I will never go to
SeaWorld [ __ ] you what a party rules to
go no no I'll never take me anywhere
watching a TV in the light 3 p.m. the
entire I want to see some ooh
what do you name it kid again ha
calories no relation little red little
Tori's I want to go to see Rose gonna
make me so happy Bobby Oh field trip
without good job Joe's gonna take me
yeah thank you
and we're gonna go to the San Diego Zoo
I haven't been there in a long time very
nice my name is okay the Lions always
scaping every time I never see the
[ __ ] lion
you gotta go ah air horn yeah
you go to the wild safari they go today
that lions are sleeping I'm like again
I cook every year the sleeping Safari
because I went to the zoo and I saw the
lion it was pretty cool they were awake
like all the [ __ ] not on the track oh
if they know you want to see world
they're like [ __ ] this guy we're going
to I don't care about no [ __ ] orcas
in Shiloh they don't even live in a same
plane okay new workers a man got
convicted of what defamation and find
four thousand dollars after liking
facebook comments over the comment no
worries
yeah you got sued four thousand dollars
for defamation in scrunchy cos he likes
comments on Facebook examination of
characterful collimation in court in
Switzerland just convicted a man about
the chocolates and closer appetizers
like they eat chocolates in court in
Switzerland Your Honor I'd like to
present al-qaeda it it like a thing
where sweet like Sweden makes the best
search on and Swiss chocolate or
Switzerland not Sweden I'm sorry Sweden
is IKEA whistlin is watches and
chocolates specifically the ones that
have the powder around them and they're
super soft oh you're talking about the
trouble yes we started it's like if you
touch it it starts melting you got to
hurry up and eat them oh they got
chocolate powder all over it chocolate
powder chocolate product so this guy he
did get sued for defamation
just by liking comment on date what
what was he liking though what were the
comments like I like rape thumbs up yeah
yes those are like you know so he was
liking comments that were post on
Facebook about this animal rights
activist that was being accused of
anti-semitism racism and fascism yeah
that's so ironic so he's an animal
rights activist is an anti-semite know
they're they're claiming like they're
beaut I love koalas bro [ __ ] hate you
I mean yep that's what is essentially
being accused accused of yet
that's hilarious not the fact thing is
because I don't know who this animal
rights activist is at all they don't
really mention him a lot of agents crew
focus on the fact that this man got sued
for defamation the whales Barbra Jean's
that's crazy that's [ __ ] great so you
liked it do you like them and so I don't
know what's happening with whoever is
involved with posting those things but
they're just saying that by him liking
these clients that he was adding to the
defamation pretty much I mean was he
defaming that's what I don't know mmm I
don't know who it is but they're just
saying that like he further distributed
this indirectly endorsing these comment
I like this though because at least once
again people are held accountable for
the [ __ ] that they're doing online I
think this is going to happen more and
more often because like social media
what's going on right now is considered
just slightly recreational but it's
becoming more and more integrate to how
people communicate so it's like in the
books now so as this becomes a staple of
society there's gonna be more and more
situations like this because right now
nobody's held accountable for their [ __ ]
yeah I actually like this because this
is the step in the right direction but
like it's a like button tote well that's
a little extreme if he commented yeah
let's save the frogs and [ __ ] burn
all Jews or whatever then it's like okay
whatever you're contributing to this
thing you're also you're also doing hate
speech online maybe I'm saying like I
don't like this extreme but I feel like
something of this sort or the lesser it
should be done like where people should
be held accountable for the [ __ ] that
they do I think so too
did you mention though that like when he
was liking these comments it was before
Facebook changed their liking experience
like when you can do like the sad face
of angry face or all those different
expressions so we don't really
necessarily know if he was liking the
class all right cuz like someone like
could write buddies before they had the
emoji cigarette like oh my grandma died
today and you like it but doesn't mean
you like you're just acknowledged
reddit other likes could your grandma
died yeah so this man does have the
right to appeal this so I don't know if
you will but thank you should connect
Lima yeah you should do it that's kind
of crazy crazy i likey
so they got a four thousand dollar fine
$4,100 mine that's expensive my money
being found guilty you think he could
also pay in chocolate what is this world
that were critical so you can't be a
chocolate because even though the land
of chocolate so everyone has chocolate
but that's the motive courtesy Oh
chocolate yeah you don't you there are
you clearly originally they don't grow
it there they have to grow it in a
tropical place what is another
stereotype or I wouldn't call it with
people being Switzerland about besides
chocolate nice fine watches yeah watches
the knives and the Swiss night the
chocolate key oh geez fondue fun yeah
huge day now anyone else yep skiing ski
mm-hmm what about the yodeling lovely
German it is too good remember we went
there we've got yodeling for our b-roll
mad people you know for no reason not
any kind you know like like if you go
back to Asia all Asian music back in the
day to folk music it sounds like you're
ice cream cookie the flats Rashad yeah
they use all the black keys of the piano
and I think all those like dramatic type
people's they all have a similar
background to so it's all it's not like
a turkey singing you're a lizard oh why
do they go to him does it hurt or
something cause I'm I don't know I know
that is it need a break up
because the Swiss Alps connects to the
Austrian Alps and I think connects to
the German out today that's how they you
can hop together have you guys heard a
Korean folk music like from back in the
day where the time is a crime the whole
time yes it is the work my grandpa had
that [ __ ] in records and he will play
that [ __ ] right to help him fall asleep
can you give an example of what I do
it's hard you just always always crying
like I can't even imitate it's hard okay
I don't like so much whaling provide a
funeral yeah it's not like am I will
endure sorrow in it can you can you find
a song okay look for Korean I can't even
imitate it classic Korean folk your
grandpa had [ __ ] vinyls like vinyls
and he's [ __ ] like we would go into
the variations of Korean folk it might
be but there's like because there's a
lot of like pain in our in our history
so our our music was about getting
[ __ ] over it's quite the opposite of
Multani Midway we're here that we could
hear the word no that's not it that's
not it but in the variation of Korean
folk song come on now anything car like
that sounds like some Orchestra [ __ ]
yeah I will get those vinyls at home and
I'll bring it all on you I hate it like
saranghae but without on okay let's go
don't even know what that means in doubt
this is a it sounds like they're funky
no this is like a chance that sounds
like some north of North Korean
children's choir yeah but my grandpa
would used to be [ __ ] spinning that
[ __ ] like it was a dopest thing on earth
you know when you watch like those war
movies and then when the person likes
pretty much dying and they show like the
desert oh that Middle Eastern thought
the Korean version of that yes except
there's success they're saying happy
birthday
but it's like sorrows like seeing about
sorrow and my weeping for the country
and everything is like god dammit dude
what a creepy play everybody loved [ __ ]
anyways going back to this whole paper
like drink to achieve a seeing as like
now that there's real consequences based
off of whatever you put out there on
online do you guys think that you'll be
going back in reviewing everything every
no absolutely not because mine has been
for comedic purposes it means people
laugh the sarcasm in it there's a levity
you know I mean so mine is not to hurt
people is to bring humor into dark
situations so anything if something
resurfaces for something like really
said like years ago it comes back you're
getting all that backlash would you take
a bag oh because I put it up there but
see that's different though there's a
lot of people now who I feel like they
always delete stuff because they have
like cover their tracks
never company that won't worry about to
you know what I mean and like their
image my image has been tarnished is day
one so there's nothing new you never
mean I've been cursing like restore my
cotton actually have gotten a lot nicer
than it used to be like Honda use being
worse so I had to dumb it down because
people are becoming too sensitive
so anything if you're digging up dirt it
had to be recently it had to be like
pretty recently I said some stupid [ __ ]
when I was young I hope they get my AOL
files I would like to read them yeah I
control the [ __ ] out of chat rooms
remember that chat rooms oh yeah how are
you doing ah I actually would have I
just been more embarrassed there's
nothing in my past that would ever close
controversy it's just more like writing
with like these instead of th's and the
reduce kind of thing see is I just
stupid self up that's cool when
yesterday so we knew I'd like type with
like small capital yeah small capital
right Asian like small little a and then
a big head and then a little in a large
writing Asian all the time probably yeah
she's interesting too cuz like oh god
sorry so this is bigger like I think I'm
a comedian too like when you go back
into the embarrassing things you could
laugh at like the world you laughing
with you
- cuz it's so [ __ ] stupid and
whatever story that you think is dumb
about us I'm pretty sure I've already
told it you know I mean so it's not I
think it's different so like if you're
like this
well put-together let's see a beauty
blogger right hi my name is davina Lee
I'm in CC aware whatnot and I have like
this this certain type of following when
people think I'm perfect but then they
find they're saying opposed to Mir I'm
like what's up [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] your babies in the face you know
that is like whoa what happened but you
find a post about me where I'm saying
stupid [ __ ] or even let's say
embarrassing emotional [ __ ] right I will
crack the [ __ ] up - yeah what's up guys
thanks for watching we are going to
regularly start posting content on the
JK films Instagram so make sure you
follow us there a lot video click over
here
[Music]